i am here today with a man who has won
world titles and just about every
promotion he's ever stepped foot in they
call him captain charisma so i'll try
and keep that same energy christian cage
how are you doing man
not bad how you doing good to see you
again
it's good to see you uh i know you know
the day has gone on so i want to know
are you still enjoying a hot grande
americana with one stevia these days
i had two already today
yeah i had one on my drive report coming
home and then one on the
at the airport when i got there so yeah
i'm
i'm uh i'm glad my americanos are
good very nice i get my little nardwar
dig in there um so with the last time we
spoke it was actually the day after uh
your aew dynamite debut against frankie
kazarian and now as we're you know
heading into 2022 i'd like you to just
sort of recap how does it feel being
part of aw thus far because you were
there for the peak of the attitude era
you were there for the prime years of
tna impact how does it feel in this
stage of your career to be again like
with a promotion that's just running as
hot as aew is
uh it's it's it's a gift it really is i
mean to get my career back to be able to
take it back um after losing it for
seven years is pretty special and you
know for me
at this stage i just wanted the right
platform where i could um
i could uh
you know finish my career on the the way
that i
you know wanted to
to
to do it i wanted to do it on the
biggest stage as i could and
a place that would give me the best
opportunities and um again along with
that being able to help out the
generation coming up behind me so
um aew is the perfect fit for me in that
respect and having one conversation with
tony
um about it um
i wasn't even halfway through the the
conversation with him and i was like
this is the place for me and it was
based solely off of him
and
obviously he'd assembled a great roster
of talent but more than anything i
wanted to i wanted to work for for him
and i wanted to um to be a part of aw
uh and help it grow and it's amazing
that like not even a full year even from
where i started to where we're at now
you know with uh
brian danielson showing up and seeing
punk showing up and uh just games game
changing stuff you know and it's a
destination where people they want to as
performers they want to be in aw they
want to be a part of this and they see
what we're doing on a weekly basis and
for me
it's this is the most fun and this is
the most excited i've been
in my my long career wow and you know
you did get to headline opposite kenny
omega at all out in 2021 one of the
company's biggest pay-per-views on a
night like you said we saw the debut of
brian danielson we saw the debut of adam
cole
where does that match rank and that
evening rank in your career when you
think about all the elements not only
was it a huge night for fans but you got
to go in there with kenny omega our
fellow canadian who for years has been
declared one of if not the best wrestler
active
right yeah no it was you know for me
it's one of those things where you know
i had heard buzz about kenny for years
but never really seen a full match of
his until um you know he was really kind
of on top in new japan and when i
watched his matches at that point and
if i could have gotten the ring with
this guy we could have done some special
stuff and um
you know until then who would have like
they were just it was what ifs you know
like dream match type stuff and to be up
uh actually able to get in there
and have a couple matches with him um
you know we had the match in the first
episode of rampage where i beat him act
title um and then so hey we're one and
one we just thought that the rubber
matcher at some point deadline
it was it was huge and to be able to
headline um to this point the biggest
pay-per-view um that aw has ever put on
is is pretty special it's not lost on me
the um
that opportunity that i had to to main
event that paperwork it's pretty pretty
big
you talked about getting your career
back and when we talked last time um one
of the best pieces of advice you got
from doctors regarding your concussions
was just go in there and don't worry
about any of it right just wrestle as
you know how to wrestle i do have to ask
i can't admit i was a little scared for
a second when you took that crazy bump
off the top rope with kenny omega that
one winged angel can you can you talk me
through uh that maneuver talking about
it before the execution
yeah well i mean i got up there and i
was and and you know that match and when
he stood up i was i was like
well there's no getting out of this now
i mean it was it was pretty damn high
not gonna lie uh it was it was jarring
you know but it was
um
uh but when you're out there and your
adrenaline's kicking and you know you're
you're in that type of match in the main
event um you know it's uh
you really don't feel it in the moment
but it was
it was it was there it was it was a big
one sure well i know again i love the
match it was an amazing one uh you
mentioned
as well as your role as an active
wrestler sort of helping to mold the
next generation of aew stars currently
are aligned with lucha soros jungle boy
of jurassic express how fulfilling has
it been for you because you know you you
as a tag team as a singles wrestler
coming up had your own mentors how
fulfilling is it to now be able to give
back to younger wrestlers that's huge
the the business all about giving back
and and um you know this it's given me
so much in my life that that i wanna i
do want it to share i don't know
everything but i feel like i know a lot
and you know i'm still learning this
business too we're all we're all
learning that's a beautiful thing about
it you're never you never finished
learning um as a performer so
um but the knowledge that i do have i'm
very happy to share especially with with
people that want to learn and the
younger younger stars that want to learn
and the two guys that i'm with jungle
boy luchasaurus
they're sponges man like i talked with
like they pick my brain like we're
we are a legit team like we we hang out
together we talk together we talk we
talk during the week we're not um at the
arena you know we keep in touch and
we're always brainstorming and i love
their enthusiasm in turn gives me
enthusiasm you know just seeing the
hunger in their eyes and and like with
jungle boy for example you know he he's
mentioned this before that he was kind
of shy about talking about doing promos
and interviews and things like that and
i feel like i've helped him come out of
his shell and give him confidence and
when you have confidence
um you can kind of do no wrong so he's
every time he's he's speaking at this
point those are his words and um
you can just feel the confidence every
every time that he gets up to bat um
with one of these promos or interview
segments and he's
um every every time he gets wraps he's
just getting better and better and
better more
confident i can see it in him and i'm so
proud of him because i really think
you know he's a future face of aew i
really think he has that kind of
potential and talent and luchasaurus of
course you know the old saying you can't
teach size but the the athleticism this
guy has at his size it's unbelievable
and that the sky's the limit for both of
them and for me to be a small part and
helping them realize their full
potential is huge for me
yeah you've really seen jungle boy come
out of his shell in the last six months
or so um now you are aligned with them
so i want to deviate from that a bit if
you had to pick one aew star one of the
young guys who's got the most potential
besides jungle boy and lucha source who
would you kind of have your eye on
oh man i mean it's hard to pick just one
uh you can name a few i'm not holding
you to it
i think there's the obvious ones like mj
up i mean he's he's
very gifted um you know on the
microphone obviously and that kind of
sometimes even out shadows the fact that
he's he's very good in the ring and
um
i look at a guy like ricky starks who's
also uh super talented he's good he can
really talk um he's got a good he's got
that kind of aura about him something
there's something there with him um he
has potential to be a huge star um as
well
and you know i
those are the kind of two guys off the
top of my head that that i think
are
pretty damn good
uh there's always an influx of you know
the right stars in aew and there's one
that's closely aligned to use i just
want to pick your brain what is what is
your impression of uh or would you like
to see
your old buddy jeff hardy make his way
to aew eventually
yeah of course i mean uh there's so much
history there and you know um
i
you know obviously i'm very close with
with matt as well and uh it's like it's
been super um
it's been it's been great to to
reconnect with him and aw and he's kind
of doing the same thing as far as
mentoring the younger
generation
the same way and he's also got a wealth
of knowledge so
you know and jeff is a
extremely talented guy really good guy
um and so i'm sure that uh at some point
that would happen
um one of the most iconic catchphrases
in all of wrestling is of course when
stone cold steve austin or the crowd
chance what and from what i understand
you had a
rather unintentional role in the
development of that catchphrase can you
tell me about the origins of steve
austin's wet chance yeah so steve and i
would sometimes we would just call each
other if we're on like drives just to
you know joke around and make each other
laugh and just do ridiculous stuff
and we flew into
chicago but we had a show and i think i
believe it was rockford illinois that
night and so was it like an hour hour
and a half drive from chicago so we
decided to stay in chicago and work out
and there was this gym that was like
downstairs and when you went downstairs
you lose cell phone signal so
uh we were downstairs in the gym steve
decided to drive on the town i guess he
was bored he called me and went straight
to my voicemail and he started leaving
me
um this crazy message where he just
started asking himself questions and
answering them with what and then like
he's like hey they might stop at this
rest stop over here what i said i'm
gonna stop at this rest stop what i said
i'm gonna stop like he would just like
repeat that and just about anything i
guess that he was that came that he saw
at that moment in time he would he would
say something about it and
i was laughing because it was so
ridiculous and i asked him at the
the arenas what was that message he's
just laughing at that and i was just
messing around you know just and then
literally a week or two later i'm
sitting in the locker room uh at tv
and i can hear him in the ring doing his
promo on live television and also when i
hear him start doing what and i'm like i
can't believe that he's doing this
in front of the crowd and he's going to
get it over i know he is and that's how
kind of how it started
and boy did it get over uh you know
since it's et canned i'm curious is it
true that your ring name christian cage
is a combination of christian slater and
nicholas cage
history yeah yeah what what sparked that
so i always kind of like
like the last name cage i thought that
was like a pretty awesome like last name
to have
and uh
so i was sitting with a friend of mine
and it was right before my first kind of
match
and i didn't really have a stage name so
i was uh
throwing names around and like i said i
kind of had the name cage floating
around in my head already
and
you know i said what about this what
about that and then the show
extra was on the extra entertainment
show
and it came on and was doing a piece on
christian slater
so i looked at the tv and i just turned
to my friend and i said what about
christian cage
he goes ah that name kind of sucks
show and then we'll change it after i
was like okay so then it uh it stuck
that was the uh that was the name for my
first match and then that just stuck and
went from there
uh i know nick cage is acting as a very
uh heatly debated topic which side of
the line do you fall on
i think he's i he was in my at the time
one of my favorite actors so
yeah i like him too i think i saw this
whole video essay on the fact that like
if you sort of open your mind to what
acting can be instead of what it
traditionally is that nick cage is
actually pretty good and you see it in
some of these roles like mandy where he
can be like really crazy and it fits the
theme of the movie it's actually pretty
great
yeah and face off was a great movie too
yeah the nicholas cage come back at 2021
i'm all here for it uh speaking about
the years heading into 2022 what are
your aew goals
yeah i mean it's
i mean obviously you know
my goal is always to be to be the best
and um
i feel like
my comeback
has been
everything i'd hoped it would have been
you know getting some big opportunities
um
i obviously won a world championship
already this year with impact world
title but i came to aw
um with that goal in mind to to hold the
aw championship as well so um i'll put
my sights on that for uh for 2022 and
keep myself in good physical condition
and um get ready to you know keep
putting on some great matches
as we wrap up you've been around for a
long time where do you see aew by the
end of 2022
and even bigger and
better i was i was thinking about it
like
um
you know it would be depending on
obviously what happens with with with
everything in the world it would be nice
to kind of branch out and get to some of
these
um you know
we have a huge following in europe and
canada be at some point would be great
to
to to
figure out how to get some shows there i
mean i don't know if it's going to be
2022 but eventually that hopefully will
happen and um but you know i would love
to to you know take the show to um
obviously our audiences in other parts
of the world that um are kind of
clamoring for you know yeah i gotta get
you to the hometown of toronto over to
vancouver so i can check one out live
fantastic christian before i let you go
and i don't know if this fits the tone
of the interview but i put out a reddit
q a usually just to get some fan input
and once in a while someone writes in
something super interesting and
as someone who's had those burning
questions that i feel like i can never
get answered i want to give this person
their due
and they wrote i was about nine or ten
at a house show in des moines where
christian faced booker t for the
intercontinental title even as a kid i
knew the titles usually don't change
hands if it wasn't televised in this
match booker was going for the scissor
kick and seemed steemtoe thrown out his
back christian then went for the pin to
win the title was it a legit injury and
an impromptu finish
it was a legit injury it was uh but he
was um taking time off after that
uh they heal up so that it was a legit
injury okay so the plan the plan was for
christian to win the title that night um
yeah but it was also one of those cool
things where
you know let's keep some interesting
live events going you know if like
you know
when big things happen on them and at
that time like you said
no title change is really happening on
live events so um with something to kind
of get some chatter going
yeah well that's my holiday gift to that
one user because i know they've been
waiting for decades to have that answer
so i'm happy i have to do that uh
christian man this was awesome as always
thank you so much for doing it dude
yeah my pleasure is always good to talk
to you
you